so we read small change where the author
criticized small businesses
their work in countries where
inequalities exist and you said that
you're providing services to these
people who would otherwise not have them
what the author of small change would
say is that businesses ignore the fact
are the roots of the cause of inequality
and would rather just use the inequality
to their service by providing their
goods and by almost creating a monopoly
would you say that this is correct that
businesses can't affect much past
providing services that they can't
create the social movement and the civil
society that's needed to remove the
inequality completely I actually think
that that's a very myopic view of of
small businesses and their origins and
and how they develop I'll give you an
example at the moment I'm working with
the gates foundation on a medical clinic
fund that they're going to invest in on
doing the due diligence for them so I'm
looking at on their behalf the viability
of small businesses are small primary
health care providers that is the only
source in in almost all cases for lower
income groups of any health care if they
can afford it in the first place so I
don't I don't get how someone can say
give you what you've just asserted on
that behalf I mean you know they're not
exploiting inequality they are doing
what little is being done to try to
attend an enormously overlooked
unattended discriminated marginalized
group so i think it's i actually think
statements like that are quite
irresponsible I think also you would
have seen all sorts of changes and
perhaps even unrest if you think about
the fact that in many of the countries
that we're talking about the SME sector
the smaller medium-sized enterprise
sector accounts for sometimes up to
ninety percent of economic output it
just stands to that makes a bit of a
nonsense I think about thank you I think
you are avoiding a question right what I
hear implicit in or its question is it
is we accepting what you said that you
have expanded business services even in
health care
it could be in a system that's
incredibly exploitative yes which there
is massive inequality where women are
treated as a in a very suboptimal way
that it's not addressing that it is
simply addressing providing and
expanding necessary services but not
addressing fundamental inequalities in
that particular society do you disagree
with them no I don't disagree I think
that's a fair point i mean i think that
one also has to be realistic about how
many issues a single business can take
off you know so for example back to the
financial services example we had before
when investing are we going to work with
that institution to look at
discrimination by gender and literacy
and physical you know there's a limit to
what each institution we do but no I
think that is that's a fair statement